ce mercredi soir à damas un avion
transportant un total de 2016 kits de
test covit 19 a atterri à l'aéroport
international de la capitale
ce premier don de matériel en provenance
de pékin a été réceptionné par le vice
ministre syrien des affaires étrangères
fayçal meqdad et l'ambassadeur de chine
en syrie
fang biya au top de la république arabe
syrienne
en tant que dirigeants et peuple
apprécie cette aide que nous avons reçu
des dirigeants et du peuple chinois
car elle montre un réel souci d'aider la
syrie et tous les pays à surmonter la
pandémie qui frappe le mans la syrie
allié solide de la chine au moyen-orient
est frappé de plein fouet par le virus
des camps de réfugiés menacé par la
pandémie
ce organiste dans celui d'al rôle au
nord-est du pays
des tentes sont aménagés afin de mettre
en place une quarantaine pour ces
personnes privées d'accès aux soins
médicaux
on a fait un mort il n'y a pas
d'inflexion nouveau coronavirus dans le
camp pour le moment donc deux jours une
quarantaine composé de tentes sera mis
en place en cas d'apparition d'un cas
d'infection au coronavirus celui ci sera
soumis à une quarantaine et des
organisations telles que l' oms seront
contactés si les symptômes du
coronavirus ont confirmé le patient sera
envoyé dans les organisations où il
pourra effectuer les démarches
nécessaires en dehors du cours normal
on les romans de le graet la zone un
trajet
des camps surpeuplés que beaucoup ont
fui dans l'espoir d'échapper au virus
des familles entières de déplacés
syriens ont ainsi fait le choix de
rentrer dans leur ville natale détruite
par le conflit plutôt que de rester dans
ces camps nous étions dans le nord
d'idlib et là bas les camps de déplacés
sont bondés avec la surpopulation
on a eu peur de la propagation du
coronavirus on a décidé de rentrer même
si nos maisons sont détruites
nous préférons vivre dans les décombres
le nord est aujourd'hui une zone très
peuplée les personnes déplacées vivent
les unes sur les autres dans chaque
maison il y avait trois ou quatre
familles qui vivaient ensemble
ce n'était pas possible surtout avec le
coronavirus j'ai eu peur pour les
enfants et je suis rentré à ryad depuis
le début de la pandémie
la syrie a pris les décisions strictes
pour limiter au mieux la propagation du
virus
des mesures entraînant notamment la
fermeture de restaurants de boîte de
nuit d'écoles et d'université ainsi que
l'imposition d'un couvre feu nocturne